les efforts diplomatiques se poursuivent
pour désamorcer la crise en première
ligne aujourd'hui le royaume-uni qui
appelle la russie à retirer ses troupes
près des frontières du craignent-elles
londres a donc dépêché à moscou sa
ministre des affaires étrangères elle
s'est entretenue avec son homologue
russe sergueï lavrov qui estime que les
ultimatums et les menaces de l'occident
visant la russie ne mène à rien la
correspondance à moscou de faire un
cauchemar
qu'ont prévu pas de percée après les
pourparlers des chefs des diplomaties
russe et britannique
les négociations ont duré presque deux
heures au lieu d'une initialement prévu
mais n'ont pas apporté de progrès
significatifs pia selon sergueï lavrov
la partie britannique refuse d'entendre
les arguments de la partie russe
notamment concernant les préoccupations
du kremlin quant à l'expansion de l'otan
vers l'est et l'envoi des milliers de
soldats dans les pays limitrophes russe
écoutez
l'audio 20e store
pour être honnête je suis déçu qu'on est
une conversation qui soit un dialogue de
sourds on entend mais on ne s'écoute pas
du moins nos explications détaillées
sont arrivés sur un terrain mal préparée
c'est à peu près la même chose quand on
dit que la russie attend que le sol
jallet deviennent durs comme la pierre
pour que les chars puissant très
calmement sur le territoire ukrainien il
me semble que c'était ce même terrain
chez nos collègues britanniques
aujourd'hui
à scruter les tôles évoque la
liste rose quand elle a continué de
proférer des menaces à l'égard de la
russie en vue de ces projets supposés
d'invasion de l'ukraine tout en
affirmant que le but principal de sa
visite était d'empêcher la guerre
écoutez
la raison pour laquelle je suis ici à
moscou aujourd'hui que la russie à un
choix très clair elle peut soit suivre
la voie de la diplomatie travailler avec
l'otan pour améliorer la sécurité
européenne soit poursuivre sur le chemin
qu'elle a tracée en amassant les troupes
à la frontière de manière menaçante
la visite de lys trust fut un événement
sans précédent selon sergueï lavrov la
dernière visite du ministre des affaires
étrangères britannique remonte à 2010
est le poste était alors occupée par
boris johnson premier ministre actuel du
royaume uni un lourd contentieux
subsistent entre les deux pays à cause
du dossier ukrainien mais aussi de la
sphère skripal la visite de lys trust
sera suivie demain par l'arrivée à
moscou du ministre britannique de la
défense benoît loos il doit rencontrer
son homologue russe sergueï choïgou ce
serait également une visite assez
importante car une première depuis 2013